bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fari j
oggi siamo su un nuovo videogame
indiehorror si chiama poker lander ed è
una versione this lander con i pokémon
c'è una cosa
un'idea pazza praticamente non so chi
cazzo venuto in mente si da rifare un
gioco legge ah no c'è scritto da shana
basse e speriamo non sia un gioco del
cazzo comunque noi proviamo c è
non so se fa paura come svendere o cose
del genere ma direi di no ok sia acceso
anche la luce questo fa paura
direi di iniziare allora start game a si
parte proprio subito vai cos'è ma i
pochi le mie poche bossi sono disperse
qui ok allora praticamente era che lo
scopo del gioco sarebbe trovare le poche
ball al posto delle pagine this lander
è una cosa un po strana ma va abitato
certo furgoncino cioè non so come cazzo
poi a rientrarci sembra quello dei clown
quindi non so che cosa ci sto a fare qui
ma comunque cerchiamo alle poche ball
devono andare a battere la lega mi
servono
vedo già qualcosa in tra l'altro su
cos'è sta roba c'è una anzi può spegnere
anche la torcia come ho fatto che per
vento bene c'è un edificio fantastico ai
pokémon center bene andiamo a mettere a
posto
andiamo a rimettere in sesto i miei
pokémon che non c è mi scusi c'e nessuno
devo mettere in sesto i pokémon c'è
qualcuno non c'e neanche i pokemon che
cazzo ci vengo a fare qui dentro
vabbè c'è anche il piano di accenti
piani sopra buono andiamo a vedere cos'è
sta roba
ho trovato una perché volessi sentita
male c'e tantissimo cazzo andare piano
porca [ __ ] mi sto già pagando addosso
chi è quello c'è qualcuno buongiorno
guardi che è vietato entrare senza poche
voi qui e io no già una è il brutto
straw cosa fai ti sta ignorando cos'è
sta roba
buongiorno ci ha mica qualcosa da me che
cazzo sta succedendo aiuta ci sono ruoli
sinistri cosa successo a rientrare
brutto bastardo cazzo devo tornare a
pieno di sotto per che sta succedendo
qualcosa che non so cosa ok c'è qualcuno
ho sentito che cazzo erano per i muri di
prima ok ragan già arcene di bach e già
mi vieta cos'è cos'è cos'è
raga io me ne vado dico assolutamente
bene andiamo da qualche cos'è sta roba
perché c'è un muro verde io direi di
entrare qui dentro qualsiasi posto è
meglio di quello dove ero prima
cos'è sta roba mi fate capire che cazzo
è un labirinto fantastico come se non
bastasse ci sarà una pochi col spero
devo cercare di non perdermi qui dentro
anche se sarà abbastanza difficile
raga mi sono perso cazzo non proprio la
strada per tornare indietro
bene non so come si fa maledizione c'era
che i due ore che gira a vuoto non trovò
porca [ __ ] e due ore che stavo lì
dentro
vabbè abbiamo capito che qua dentro non
ci deve entrare anche se non so che
cazzo nasco cos'è quella roba lì e di
nuovo il pokémon center di prima cos'è
non mi piacciono sti posti a caso era
capito che cos'è sta roba è un muro a un
muro di qualcosa un muro di no cosa un
edificio non sembra dei pokémon sta roba
va bene entriamoci lo stesso allora che
c'è una scala per so che per me
il cazzo di pianoforte devono entrare
qui dentro ci sarà qualcosa presumo devo
andare cos'è cos'è cos'è è una cosetta
un caricatore una candela che cazzo è
che cazzo sono sti pianoforti che mi
danno fastidio voglio capire che una
morte modern epness yen
c'è una porta si è perché cazzo non
entrano vento crema e ci siamo allora
siamo a 2 poké ball
voglio capire di chi minchia e
pianoforte prima che io lo spacco sulla
testa
allora c'è un'altra camera da letto
pieno quella di prima perdo
l'orientamento non riesco a girarmi c'è
va bene continua a suonare tranquillo
calcio cioè il talento c'è anche il
sotterraneo cosa ci faccio qui sotto a
dei ragazzi rei di tornare indietro
perché non capisco che cosa ci faccio
ancora qui dentro è una roba cosa fosse
saltare questo fa sì faccio vecchio
allora ragazze non mi dite chi sta
suonando il pianoforte
vi giuro che faccio un casino non c'è ke
kazzo sto successo visto bloccando
maledizione
che cosa cazzo è quella roba o mio dio
poli waka aiuto che cazzo ci addita
visto inseguendo cosa ci fa un po
linguaggio che cazzo sta facendo quello
non è pistola ad acqua
quello è pistola sangue maledizione
aiuta il cazzo sta succedendo perché è
un po league sta tentando di stuprarmi
buongiorno che cazzo cos'è max lei si è
ok
che cazzo succede senti non è sicuro qui
ci sono degli schizzi di sangue
non so se il tuo sto poké ball ma te la
prendo
senti c'è un po di vaghi in giro che
tentava di stuprarmi prima scappa ti
prendo io viene in braccio cazzo scappa
da lì c'è un po e l'iva che volete
stuprare la gente dove andato dove è
andato aiuto
no cos'è oddio dark rai che cazzo ci fa
qui a mio zio ma si può
stanno tentando di superarci scappa da
scanditi da vecchie parte
oh mio dio è qualcosa di traumatico non
li vedo più perché vedo tutto nero
cazzola e via praga il personaggio è
come al solito 1 peso che non riesce a
correre
porca [ __ ] non c'è verso non mi sta
seguendo più nessuno almeno quello raga
un minuto di silenzio per il bambino
stavo guardando la tomba stava cercando
di leggere non sapevo ancora lei una
poké ball perfetto 2
aiuto aiuto non prendi prendi prendi
premi per i vai vai scappa brutto
stronzo mangia meno hamburger
porca [ __ ] non riesce a correre ma si
può ok non c'è più nessuno non c'è
nessuno mai la in lontananza vedo
qualcosa
cazzo devo scappare ma che cazzo ma se
lo fai a correre due metri devi fare
idiota ma porca [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] corri madonna mia
santissima ma non si possono 46 ve ne
mancano due va dai aiuto sono ovunque
cazzo rai che ho bisogno di aiuto
seriamente questo affare non corre cosa
cela porca [ __ ] sono ovunque vi stanno
circondando merda mi mancano due fottute
poké ball e ho vinto ma non corre sta
merda non corre perché non ha mangiato
12 hamburger stamattina a colazione e
non fa più di due passi senza cadere
molto stecchito non si può direi di di
stare un secondo calmi e fare punto
della situazione
mi mancano due fottute pokémon c'era un
bambino che è stato stuprato poverino
e vabbè mi ha rovinato l'infanzia sto
gioco del cazzo allora la gala
situazione particolare non solo che
cazzo ha di nuovo il furgone ancora non
ero dimenticato la poche volte il
furgone che c'era all'inizio che non ho
guardato è possibile perché tipo dietro
c'è qualcosa che luccica se la vedo
se uno non è un no a roma tra l'altro
che cazzo di tubo di scarico già sta
roba fatemi capire
porca [ __ ] via via via via via via
via via via merda provo alle 4 perché
voi che ciò spero di avere almeno un
magica che con slash faccio fuori tutti
la cosa positiva di questo videogame è
che dietro gli alberi non ci sono
allenatori pronti a sfidarsi perché sono
già stati tutti stuprati dove cazzo sono
tra l'altro c'è un cimitero che non ho
capito cosa ci sta a fare spero ci sia
una forte bosè 55 su 6 dai 56
farcela ottiche che cazzola un addio no
oddio il perché con lei è un leggendario
maledizione fi
scatta stanno tentando di stuprarmi
tutti faccio 5 poké ball un apporto
lanciarvi e la cazzo
raga mi sa che dobbiamo rientrare nei
labirinti lì ce ne sarà di sicuro una
che ho dimenticato di sicuro devo
provare ad entrarci calcio è pieno
entriamoci subito
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
speriamo mentre entra cazzo sembra la
sembra che la polizia mi sta inseguendo
tra l'altro porca [ __ ] occupa tutto
aiuto non c'è via di fuga ma non ci
credo non ci credo che le mancava una ma
porca [ __ ] l'edizione raga è un gioco
senza un [ __ ] senso l'ho fatto più
che altro perché ero curioso di vedere
che cosa mica era sto poche slann there
non lo rifarò mai più questo è sicuro
questo perché da adesso in avanti devo
puntare a degli horror che sono molto
più pesanti di questo comunque raga
direi di finirla qui sei video vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come non
diviso trovate nella descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi